في اقصى الجنوب الشرقي لكن في قلب دائره
الاهتمام والترقب هكذا يتبلور الثقل
للانتخابي لديار بكر احدى اهم الولايات
التركيه ذات الكثافه الكرديه في الولايه
الضاربه جذورها في التاريخ سيتوجه في
الرابعه عشر من مايو نحو مليون ومئه
واربعه واربعين الفناخب لاختيار رئيس جديد
لتركيا واثني عشر نائبا في البرلمان
هموم المعيشه وشبح البطاله شواغل تسيطر
على كثير ممن التقيناهم وخاصه من الشباب
اريد تغيير الحكومه من اجل الاقتصاد
وتمهيد طريق للشباب معدل البطاله يتجاوز
10% لا يستطيع الشباب العثور على اي عمل
ان تكون الانتخابات افضل للشباب والا نندم
على الرئيس القادم اتمنى ان تسير
الانتخابات على ما يرام الاجواء
الانتخابيه في ديار بكر تشهد حضورا بارزا
لحزب اليسار الاخضر الذي يعد ممثل حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي في انتخابات هذا العام
بسبب ما يكتنف مصير حزب الشعوب من غموض في
ظل دعاوى الحظر التي تواجهه على خلفيه تهم
بدعم حزب العمال الكردستاني المصنف
ارهابيا
اقترب تحالف الشعب المعارض بحذر من كتله
حزب الشعوب الذي غرد زعيمه صلاح الدين
ديبرتاش من السجن مؤيدا المرشح الرئاسي
المعارض كمال كلتشدار
وفي المقابل تلقى تحالف الجمهور ومرشحه
الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان دعم حزب
الدعوه الحره الكردي المحافظ تتناقض هذه
الصفقات مع التوجهات القوميه داخل كل من
تحالفي الجمهور والشعب لكنها تعكس حرص كل
منهما على الصوت الكردي
للناخبين الاكراد اهميه حاسمه في هذه
الانتخابات وخاصه مع تقارب حظوظ التحالفين
الرئيسيين المتنافسين وفي ديار بكرر
ولاءات السياسيه واضحه وحاسمه ولحزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي هنا وزن كبير اتوقع ان
ينعكس في هذه الانتخابات بالنظر لدعمه
للتحالف المعارضه
على مدار عقود واجهت قطاعات من المكون
الكردي مشكلات داميه مع الدوله كان حزب
العداله والتنميه اول من سعى لحلها مفسحا
المجال للسلام والانماء ولتنفس الهويه
الثقافيه للاكراد لكنها طويت سريعا بعد
عام 2015 ويتهم حزب العمال الكردستاني
بالتسبب في ذلك وصولا الى الحقبه الراهنه
بروافدها السياسيه والاقتصاديه تطلعات
الناخبين الاكراد من جانب وتحالفات الكتل
السياسيه الكرديه من جانب اخر تضاعف من
اهميه الانتخابات التركيه المصيريه التي
ستجرى الاحد المقبل وتبقي الانظار معلقه
بما ستقوله الصناديق لاقتراع خصوصا في
جنوب الشرق التركي وليد العطار الجزيره
ديار بكر